the tagline for selling condensed matter
physics is that the whole is more than
the sum of the parts I think that would
be my my tagline for the subject the
clear example of that is is a
quasi-particle
and I will be more specific I'll say the
uh the phone on is probably an example
of what you've asked for it'll be
described light as being carried by
Elementary particles we can describe
sound as being carried by particles but
they're not Elementary bonan is like a
particle of sound and it can only exist
inside crystals uh or some other states
of condensed matter and you could say
well it's just the atoms vibrating as
the sound travels through the thing you
learn at school right sure they're an
effective description but mathematically
it's exactly the same thing you do and I
think if you want to believe that
photons are real elements of reality I
think you should admit in the same way
the phonons are fundamental real things
in reality and so I suppose the the
philosophical point I'd want people to
to have as a take-home one for this
segment is that
um emergent stuff things the way the
whole is more than the sum of the parts
things like phonons that's purely
emergent phenomenon right it's not
present in any one of the atoms there
that's vibrating it's some collective
behavior of lots of them uh but it's no
less real any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic
welcome everyone to a magical very very
mystical episode of the into the
impossible podcast with I your fearful
host Dr Brian Keating joined by a wizard
if ever there was Felix flicker Dr Felix
flicker who's joining us from Europe
Felix how are you today yeah I'm very
well thank you
it's great to be with you and to be
discussing this magical book
the magic with a K of physics
understanding the Fantastical phenomena
of everyday life Felix you know because
you're an avid listener to the podcast
that I always start each podcast with a
discussion of the book cover and its
title but even before that the actual
audio that we start the podcast with is
with none other than Sir Arthur C Clarke
who famously said any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic so we always open the podcast
with that this book has magic in the
cover and I want to take our readers
through the thought process that led you
to come up with the title the graphics
and the conspicuous lack of a dust
jacket now I've always railed against
dust jackets because I think they're
useless and the first thing you do is
take them off and they just fall into
your lap of course in my first book the
dust jacket was kind of a sample
collector for the villain of the book
which is Cosmic dust but we're not here
to talk about my favorite subject me
we're here to talk about Facebook so do
us a favor please Dr Flickr Explorer and
explain the title design and subtitle of
this book in the segment we call judging
books by their covers foreign
[Music]
well I should say uh first of all that
most of those things were really the
choice of my um uh publisher
and actually all of them are different
in the UK version uh whereas also the
choice of my other publisher
um uh that okay the dust jacket that's
something I was quite keen on as you say
I always take the dust jackets off all
my books and I just throw them in the
bin actually at some point I had a
drawer full of dust jackets because I
was like I might put it back on and then
it's been a few years and I was like you
know I'm just throwing them all in the
bin
so when it came to having my own book
published I thought well it's gonna be a
bit silly because I'm going to take the
dust jacket off my book and throw it in
the bin so you might as well make sure
it doesn't have one
um
and the title is the magic with the K
yeah what is that uh meant to represent
what is that is that a British thing
like uh like uh you guys spell things uh
now I'm blanking on something but uh
what's up you guys spell with a u that
we don't
it it's not we don't we're not that
archaic usually in the UK
um actually again the title is different
in the UK although there it's the magic
of matter magic with the CK in the US
it's the magic of physics the magic of
the CK
um I guess in both places uh I mean it
wasn't um I didn't exactly choose the
title but you know I was involved in the
discussion
um I think the the decision was made in
both places because we wanted to
emphasize that it's magic in a bit more
of a literal sense than you might have
got if there weren't okay there so
um if you said something as magic and it
didn't have a k on it I think just from
a title alone you might think someone
meant like oh it's it's magic you know
in a sort of loose sense that we
generally mean oh that's quite that was
quite magical whereas in this case I'm
really trying to draw a fairly direct
comparison to Magic in like fantasy
fiction or science fiction uh and and
just generally trying to get it what's
magical about things in the world
um so we wanted people to understand
that a glance from the cover that uh
that it's meant uh slightly more
um literally
foreign
yeah yeah it's a beautifully bound book
I I I'm a scholar of that you should
know though you shouldn't throw out the
dust jackets apparently if you have say
a rare book like uh Darwin's Origin of
Species or something like that if it
doesn't have the frontist piece or the
cover it's worth ten percent
you know I have a price with the cover
so but then I also don't want to um
treasure them as objects you know I want
to treasure them for the words and
sights and I thought well if it's
devalued to other people that's probably
good for me because it will encourage me
to keep hold of it
that's right
I read the book uh in multiple copies of
it and um I will give away one of the
copies eventually to one of my students
because it's not often I have on a
theoretical condensed matter physicist
you may be one of the few if if uh not
only Nicole younger Halpern who you
reference in the book uh her book uh was
quantum steampunk and it's not exactly
about uh you know condensed matter
physics what we're going to discuss
today uh but it is nevertheless a
similar book in that it uses sort of a
similar literary devices in terms of
imaginative openers and and so forth of
each chapter and a thread woven through
with with characters mystical and
otherwise so congratulate you on that uh
literary mechanism because it's very
captivating but we're going to talk
about the hard scientific truths of this
book and one of the things amidst the
many references to the Lord of the Rings
and uh other things that my reader my
listeners will be delighted to encounter
in this book is a discussion of what you
call the Philosopher's Stone and it's
sort of the culmination of the book not
giving a spoiler away because the
descriptions are worth savoring and
reading and listening to as I did as
well I heard the audiobook as well which
I highly recommend so you should buy all
copies Digital hard copy and audio
but it culminates with the Philosopher's
Stone uh can you explain what is the
Philosopher's Stone to you as a
theoretical condensed matter of
physicist okay I yeah we do use this
phrase sometimes and obviously it's in
the news a lot at the moment we tend to
use it uh to refer to uh room
temperature superconductors I mean we
use is that we we use like the Holy
Grail or something it's like it's the
the big thing that you always refer to
in Grants basically that maybe that's
the accurate way to phrase it so if you
can connect your work to something going
on with room temperature superconductors
then you know that then that's an easy
way to explain to people that it's
important
um so I use I try to use this idea of
the Philosopher's Stone because
um I feel like it connects to this idea
that
um well so you know the idea of a
superconductor is that it's something
that conducts electricity perfectly
without loss uh whereas any typical
metal say has some resistance
um and this means that you can't you're
always losing electricity or losing
power when you send it down down any
line over any distance and this is a
huge um
obstacle to to a more widespread
adoption of things like renewable energy
say because you know we've probably all
wondered about trying to cover the
Sahara and solar panels and just send
the electricity out all around the world
and of course that's impossible because
you lose so much of it along the way
that it wouldn't work uh now if you
could make power lines out of
superconductors that would be possible
you could send it as far as you like and
you would lose literally none so I kind
of I tried to draw this connection to
this idea of the Philosopher's Stone you
know historically Alchemists were
searching for this magical substance
which would
um prevent loss in a more General sense
like they could live forever or these
sorts of things
um and I like the idea that historically
um they were trying to transmute base
substances like lead into precious metal
like gold and you can kind of do that
you can't turn that into gold but you
you cool LED down sufficiently cold and
it does change into a new state of
matter this superconductor
um and which is arguably much more
precious than gold the much more useful
I'd say
so we had encountered each other I I
contacted you a couple weeks ago after
the announcement the startling
announcement although some say it's a
reannouncement
of the discovery of a truly room
temperature superconductor by a group at
the University of Rochester with
published peer-reviewed research nature
presented at the American physical
society meeting uh the March meeting
and I immediately thought of you and I
asked you what's going on so describe
the scene we're gonna probably open the
podcast with this description so
describe what it was like in the
Pandemonium the chaos surrounding this
announcement and explain why Beyond just
the uh the explanation that you gave of
why room temperature superconductivity
is so potentially transformative but why
was this particular announcement of this
discovery so uh so chaos inducing right
well
um I can I can describe the scene at the
the uh American physical society meeting
if you like I mean that was one of the
more exciting things that happened at
that meeting yes I don't know if it's
typically renowned for its excitement
but exactly I mean it's it's a very big
meeting it's about 10 000 people go to
this meeting every year
um it's the biggest meeting of condensed
matter physicists in the world
um
uh yeah so I was uh that I bumped you
tend to sort of walk around bump into
people you know
um other physicists and have a chat
about you know what are you working on
this sort of thing and I bumped into an
old friend from Berkeley
uh and he said oh are you going to this
uh this this meeting in a few minutes
um
and so we went along to it uh to the the
announcement of room temperature
superconductivity and it was a bit
bizarre because there's some of the
rooms are massive you know there's rooms
that are ballrooms
um where famous people give talks to you
know thousands of people and set up for
that and then there are rooms that are
very small and fit maybe 100 people
comfortably and this was in one of those
rooms and we got there and Not only was
the crowd you know we couldn't get
anywhere near the room the crowd was
covering the uh the hallway which is
itself a huge thing it's in a huge
Conference Center this is in Las Vegas
um but they're also security like lined
up on the door
and this they tried to claim this was
something to do with um uh fire safety
regulations or something but uh when I
gave my talk it was also it was in the
same size room actually very close one
on a different day uh and and that talk
was also very heavily oversubscribed
because it was in uh information Theory
so it was about um machine learning and
people were very interested in that and
again the crowd was out the door on that
one and there's no security so it wasn't
really uh I think you know maybe they
were more prepared for this one but yeah
so we're in this bizarre situation with
security shouting at us to get back it
felt like a bit of a riot which you
don't normally expect at the March
meeting I have to say
um but yeah so basically um they were
making the announcement uh it's been
republished in nature after having to uh
be retracted uh after claims of um
uh I mean the claims were about
falsified data I think so very serious
accusations rather than just um
some accident or something you know it's
it's a very heated debate and not what I
feel well enough informed about but it
was retracted from nature now it's
republished in nature
um but it was in a sort of smaller room
so so anyone who's a member of the
American physical Society can give a
talk
um anyone you know you can talk about
you could make a topic up that was it
was definitely you knew to be wrong and
you would still be allowed to give a
talk about it at this meeting now I'm
not saying that's what's happening here
but uh
um somehow it did end up in the small
room and and everyone wanted to see the
show but a lot of us didn't get to see
it
um
yeah sorry yes
well so um yeah I mean it's been
re-announced uh I I think
um
uh the the the okay A lot of people are
very skeptical about it because of
what's been happening over the last year
or so
um others aren't you know there are some
very good commencement of physicists uh
who I've spoken to personally about it
who are you know they're they're not
taking aside they're trying to look at
the the scientific result
and even if it's not a room temperature
superconductor they think there might be
something interesting there there's
stuff that can be learned and I've had
some really good conversations with
people about
um other stuff that's going on I think
the thing you know the thing that will
um
steal the deal if it is true is if when
another group independently verifies the
result and so there are people thinking
about that obviously because we are
scientists and it's not all just a a big
fun show at Las Vegas
so some of that works going on now
well uh so in preparation uh for this
call I talked to uh I talked to you as I
said but then on next week I'm going to
be talking with my UCSD colleague
Professor Jorge Hirsch I don't know if
you know oh yeah
I don't know him personally but
obviously he's uh on the other side
um yeah so yeah he's yeah so uh
foreign
go ahead well um I mean your listeners
will hear it uh next week from hush I
suppose but you know he's he's famously
the uh the counter argument to to the
authors of this paper and he got the
first one
um withdrawn basically from from nature
which you know I think that's uh it's
important that we have that kind of
scrutiny for a big claim so it yeah I
think it's good that the debate was had
certainly uh so you know it would be
interesting to hear what he has to say
about it yeah just a quick pause to ask
you for a small favor while my farm is
occupied with old Albert on it yours is
presumably freed up to leave a thumbs up
on this video really helps me a lot with
a good old-fashioned YouTube algorithm
thanks a lot now back to the video
now the claim
the claim by the Rochester team Diaz and
all and their team well I've invited him
on the podcast as well but he hasn't
replied to me
um so you know my my grand design is not
to have some you know drag out debate
fight you know where we turn things into
a tawdry brawl but to have some
illumination on the subject because as
you say it is so important one of my
past guests David Friedberg uh who's a
famous billionaire investor he he
actually said on this podcast that yeah
he would give his right arm for the
discovery of room temperature
superconductivity
um and then I pointed out while it's
been discovered and and he started
getting nervous and then he started to
say things like oh well it's uh that
team has been you know uh controversial
before and and maybe it won't hold up
and I don't I said I'm getting the saw
out David I'm sharpening up the blade uh
but uh but the one thing that he was
hanging his hat on is that it's at it's
not at um ambient pressure so can you
speak about that I mean one thing that
is confusing to me is that
um you these these strange lutonites and
and so forth lutinium or whatever it is
um you know has to be subjected to this
tremendous pressure and that's somehow
seen as disqualifying but if you look at
the pressure inside uh you know a
ceramic you know superconductor just the
internal stress and strain inside of it
how how is that not the same you know
it's incredibly high stress strain maybe
it's not uh you know it's it's intrinsic
it's not extrinsic why should that be
disqualifying simply because you you
need to construct uh you know this this
kind of static I mean it's one thing if
it was Dynamic if you had a supply you
know continuous fluctuations in pressure
to keep it at millions of Pascal but why
is that the squat why do people discount
that why is that you know transformative
in in the same way that you know room
temperature or not room temperature but
but um you know liquid nitrogen conduct
superconducting objects like uh yibiko
that those have internal stress strains
that are quite High Why do we care about
how much external pressure is applied
right well I suppose some of that's
historical with these things because
it's coming
Unity where you're talking about really
really high pressures that
um so so the older claims were that
they'd made a room temperature
superconductor under like really
phenomenal pressure
um and and it's such high pressures that
it's not realistic that you're going to
build a power line out of this stuff
um we're talking about
um things you can get in like diamond
Anvil cell so you get like um you get
diamonds because they're very hard and
you can put them under huge pressure and
they can maintain their shape roughly
and you get them down to a very very
sharp tip and then squash like a tiny
amount of stuff with that tip under huge
pressure because pressure is forced
divided by area so if your area is Tiny
then you can get these unbelievable
pressures but only in that tiny little
space certainly not over power lines
that do useful stuff
um so maybe it's the historical reason
for that so now I'm slightly unclear
about some of the claims here because um
they certainly use the phrase under
ambient conditions or something like
that so I think having to talk to other
people who know a bit more about it the
claim is that they put it under huge
pressure but nowhere near as huge as it
was before and actually much more
achievable and uh um uh more practical
conditions so so
um maybe if I answer a slightly
different question when you think about
high temperature superconductors that we
already have like like ibco that you
mentioned
um it's it's high temperature when it
can exist above the uh the boiling point
of liquid nitrogen
or the boiling point of nitrogen and
therefore you can call it with liquid
nitrogen now that's not anywhere near
ambient right that's very cold but we
call it high temperature partly because
that's so incredibly practical like
turning making nitrogen liquid is is
much much easier than say making helium
liquid and so you can do it under much
easier conditions you can carry much
around in uh in uh
um sort of polystyrene pots basically
and it's it makes it far more achievable
so the pressures we're talking about
have gone from you know not achievable
achievable by a small number of groups
on Earth to something that can be done
much more readily but then there's a
claim Beyond this that I I think there's
a claim Beyond this that you make it
under these conditions but then it can
actually survive uh when you take that
pressure off so you have to make it
under incredible conditions but then you
can survive with um without having those
extreme environments I think that's the
claim of the ambience as in you know
ambient means like sort of normal
conditions and then I think as you say
it's more like there's an internal
pressure and then you get into questions
of is this material really stable like
that or is it matter stable
um my understanding is that the group
that's that's making the claims is
already saying it's not reproducible
every time it's something like a third
of the samples can do it or something
suggesting that there's more going on
it's maybe not like
um uh you know you can have like
crystals where you have periodic
Arrangements of atoms
and then those you know we know that
crystals can be stable but then you can
have things where there's sort of like
patches regions that are superconducting
and maybe they're not connecting up
something like that
um so that would suggest maybe matter
stable perhaps it can fall apart after
some time until people have reproduced
this and understood all these different
things it's hard to make a serious
comment about it I think
so you make a strong case in the book
that condensed what we call condensed
matter physics which used to be called
solid state visit physics which some
people call squalid State Physical uh
and the mere fact that you you know are
only the second or third you know true
theoretical condensed matter physicists
I have never had a I don't think I've
ever had an experimental condensed
matter this is although I do a lot of
that for the cooling of superconducting
transition Edge sensor superconductors
for astronomical purposes we basically
have a condensed matter physics lab with
liquid nitrogen and helium and all sorts
of you know dilution refrigerators and
uh you know super fluids and so forth
but um but nevertheless it's it's not so
well known and you make the case that it
should be more well known and I wonder
if I could share a vignette so I went to
Brown University for my PhD where
Michael kosterlitz is and uh of course
he's very famous for you know sharing
the 2016 Nobel Prize with Duncan haldane
who makes an appearance in this book who
is a very strange character and I did
interview him for my my second book
which is around here somewhere
um oh yeah it's right in front of me so
uh into the impossible has an interview
with uh with the uh Duncan haldane who
was a professor here at UC San Diego
before he left for the colder climate of
Princeton New Jersey
anyway Leon uh who is my quantum
mechanics uh relativistic quantum
mechanics teacher at Brown uh he pivoted
after he won the Nobel Prize he he'd
think he would go into you know even
deeper into Super connectivity but he
turned to neural networks and and you
know kind of early machine learning back
in the early 90s uh not yeah well it was
20 years after he won the Nobel Prize
but you know 50 or 40 years after he did
the work but nevertheless why do you
think if why do you think you know a
beginning student would be interested
and well served by going into condensed
matter physics if some of the most
prolific practitioners of that
immediately abandoned the field you know
as soon as they uh acquire their their
shine gilded object called the Nobel
Prize uh what get give us give us a
little bit of of advertisement and
promotion some PR for your field okay
well I would probably at first I point
out that I think it's pretty common for
someone who wins a Nobel Prize to switch
Fields dramatically I think because
they're going for a other one right if
you if you won the Nobel Prize in the
thing you've been doing you're not going
to win another one in any closely
related field so I think um you know
John bardeen who's the only person to
win two Nobel prizes in physics
um and of course those are both in
Cadets matter uh but then my
understanding was he was going for a
third and he was attempting to get one
for um understanding high temperature
superconductors I think but you know
that's that's hearsay but uh he sort of
Switched topics repeatedly uh every time
he gets a Nobel Prize he changes again
because you're not going to get another
Nobel Prize in that direction so
uh maybe if you'd have uh lived longer
you might have made it to three right
that's the uh
we call that the hedonic treadmill you
know when you get some level of Fame and
success It's never enough you just keep
seeing one thing the number to go up
whether that's money or subscribers or
what have you so yeah so continue and I
should also point out your countrymen
um Brian Josephson who are trying to get
on the podcast he also made a radical
pivot and now works on a theory of
Consciousness in mind and and is
involved with some say quackery and and
so forth but but Leon is still on honest
to goodness you know uh work a day
scientist so anyway I'm sorry to
interrupt um no but besides the Nobel
Prize winners what what's an
advertisement what's the what's your
pitch your elevator pitch
um for a young graduate student to
pursue theoretical or experimental
condensed manifest well I'd say um the
main thing really is that while people
tend not to have heard of it I'm sure
people listening to your podcast will
have heard of it because they're you
know perhaps better informed about
physics but uh someone on the street if
you ask them have they heard of
condensed matter physics the answer is
always known and you ask them if they've
heard of gravitational waves or string
theory and they've always heard of those
things
um but I would the first point I would
make is that uh uh a third of all
physicists identify as condensed matter
physicists and that's actually more than
any other branch of physics so it's the
biggest field in physics and so clearly
physicists are seeing something in this
subject which which is not being
communicated to the public
um
so you know uh I suppose if if pitching
it to graduate students in particular is
the one argument is that there's uh
there's jobs in it
which is not necessarily true of string
theory anymore so you know we're getting
a lot of string theorists coming over to
condense matter like
not to start that old argument again I I
have some work going on on string theory
as well so you know it's both ways but
there's always going to be jobs in
condensed right
um but yeah I'd say uh it's there there
is this this uh disconnect where
physicists know about it find it
interesting lots of them work on it but
people in the public tend not to have
heard of it and I ask people over the
years why is this you know I asked other
scientists I asked like science
popularizers and journalists and the
answer was always one of two things
basically they always and I agree with
these two things one is that um
uh it's it you take subjects like
astrophysics gravitational waves string
theory and there's something like
inherently magical about those subjects
uh which doesn't need explaining so if
you look at the night sky it's easy to
be kind of awestruck by that if you said
I find that magical no one will really
say what do you mean by that I don't
know what you mean it's magical isn't it
you look at the sky are you trying to
imagine the whole universe it blows your
mind or you try and imagine like the
smallest possible things like what what
are the elementary building blocks of
the universe and those things are
inherently magical in a way that doesn't
need explaining but condense matter
physics is the study of familiar stuff
it's the stuff around us like everything
we've ever experienced is matter and the
familiar is not obviously magical in the
same way
um so you need to explain the magic
so that's one reason the other reason I
think it's less well known is that it's
practical like this discovery if they
found a real temperature superconductor
that will be put to use within like a
year or something genuinely you know
we're already using um superconducting
power lines it's just to be a matter of
switching them over so they don't use
liquid nitrogen anymore and so you might
think well that's an easy way to sell
the subject but I think it makes it
harder because
if you talk to someone who works on
black holes say they can write a book
about black holes and in their book they
explain why they're excited to work on
black holes but if a condensed matter
physicist tries to sell their subject
there's always this temptation to say
well uh I work on it because I think
it's great but the reason you might
think it's great is because it's got
these practical applications like all of
electronics relies on condensed matter
your computer your phone all this stuff
that's not why you work on it right I'm
not working on condensed matter physics
because I want your phone to work better
you know no offense that's a useful
byproduct right but that's not why I'm
excited about it so I think those are
the two problems right subject faces
it's practical and it's familiar and
neither of those things seems obviously
magical in the way that other subjects
in physics are magical and so that was
the central idea of the book I thought
well why do I find it magical and I
thought I think I think those things can
be magical it's just a slightly more
subtle form of magic and then that led
me to this idea of sort of uh it's kind
of like what a wizard does like uh you
know where's it not attempting to be
restrictive on who is a wizard but you
know you take someone like uh Harry or
Hermione and Hogwarts and they're not
doing magic on the scale of the whole
universe and they're not rewriting the
fundamental laws of reality they're
doing bits of practical Hands-On magic
that that helps other characters out and
so I thought okay so I think it is
magical but we need to explain that a
bit more clearly in our subject
so uh what I love about the book are
these illustrations which you know you
are a calligraphy Maven uh you're quite
accomplished at that as well as
um which you know I'm grateful to your
your publicist uh for letting me know
but in addition to uh Shoto or Shoto by
Shoto in Japanese calligraphy you're
also uh the former British champion of
shui Zhao which is Chinese wrestling
um tell me about this why would a wizard
need to wrestle I mean so many other
magical powers that you can uh that can
uh take part in so what what is tell me
about that you're the first wrestling
champion I've had on the podcast I've
had on Prav Maga practitioners but never
a wrestling champion what led to that
how does it how does it uh jive with you
being a theoretical physique well I mean
I've been doing um martial arts for many
years it's actually uh Kung Fu I do
um so I did that for a long time uh I
went to the um
uh our school went to the national
competition and there's various things
you can take part in
um and uh I just kind of entered the uh
situation on the day I hadn't really
heard of it before but
um I gave it a go and yeah you can just
use the same principles so uh it worked
out quite well in that case
um but yet
um praying mantis kung fu is what I have
done for many years and then I've taught
for for many years as well
um so actually that led to also to the
Japanese calligraphy
um
I guess uh I I also I'm very into tea
happy which a lot of English people are
I suppose
um and a friend of mine
um knew uh so this is in Bristol where I
where I live now and where I did did my
PhD years ago
um a friend of mine used to
um work at a place called Hamilton house
and uh every Thursday morning in
Hamilton house
um there was a Japanese man would come
there and he would do this thing called
jury energy healing and you would sit
there for 10 minutes uh and and he would
hold his hand out and he would shoot
healing energy into your face so this is
how my friend explained it to me and you
know what I try to be open-minded I I
was like I don't I suspect sitting
quietly for 10 minutes with your eyes
closed is probably the benefit you're
getting from that interaction and maybe
having someone pay attention to you like
that but my friend was always adamant
about it so he said you should go and
meet this guy
um anyway uh it turned out that the the
man's um uh wife was uh as a team master
who can do the Japanese tea ceremony
and you know this is like similar to
martial arts it takes years of practice
to do everything perfectly for this tea
ceremony and he invited me along to to
have the Tea Ceremony three of us to go
and have it
um and during the discussion around that
it turned out that his uh his wife was
also a calligraphy Master as well as
being a team master and I got very
excited about this because uh I'd
um I've been doing kung fu for years uh
part of that is learning the uh the
sword like a Chinese long sword and I'd
understood that the it's a similar skill
using the long sword to do in
calligraphy like it's always portrayed
as a quite similar art in films and so
on so I got quite excited about that and
asked if they wanted to teach me uh and
actually by the time we got around to
doing it his wife had moved back to
Japan but he he wanted to um uh teach me
himself so I learned that for a few
years and then when I moved to Berkeley
in California and um I found another
Japanese calligraphy teacher over there
who uh who also wanted to teach it so I
carried on when I was in San Francisco
I don't know so uh speaking of tea well
first I want to relate an anecdote that
I can't really remember in its fullness
but there's a story of a Japanese tea
Master who's traveling with uh with the
emperor somewhere in the 1400s or
something and he somehow he besmirches
the reputation of a of a um a samurai
warrior and the Samurai warrior
challenges him to a fight to the death
and he doesn't know uh the warrior
doesn't know he's actually not uh the
the man that he's encountering is a very
high level official in the Japanese you
know establishment uh and he also
doesn't know he's this tea master and so
the t-master is terrified and he says oh
I'm going to die and he starts
complaining to the emperor and the
emperor says agree to fight show up
tomorrow and don't flee you'll you'll
your life will be over if you flee but
do start your day as you would normally
and we'll see what happens and the
Samurai warrior Witnesses him making tea
which as you know is a very elaborate
process in Japan and elsewhere
and um when he does it he uh the
Japanese warrior says I refuse to fight
you even if you don't know anything
about samurai sword fighting arts and so
forth you are so accomplished in this
tea preparation that your mind is far
sharper than my sword and so he
surrenders and they become BFFs
um the reason I bring this up is I I
think there is a book written by my
namesake Brian Keating and it's called
how to make tea and uh people confuse me
with that author unfortunately he's
passed away very young uh sadly uh but I
have that book because I always support
people named Brian Keenan uh and I hope
everyone will do that as well except
support living bright Keating perhaps by
buying my books and the Brian Keating
book is called how to make tea and I was
like well what's the big deal you know I
was supporting a friend you know or
someone with the same name but I read it
and it's quite intricate and it goes
through the different types of boiling
water that are necessary to make
different types of tea and you recount
that in your book book and I want to use
that as a springboard to talk about
phase transitions because I always heard
you know phase transitions are sort of
you know it's kind of like the the
Supreme Court in America defined
pornography as you'll know it when you
see it I was like well how much can
there really be you know at standard
temperature and pressure to about
different types of water for tea I just
boil it and dump it in a cup I'm you
know I'm an American I drink uh the most
American Beverage of all tab I drink tab
uh but but tell me Felix what what is a
phase transition is it is it you know it
when you see it because it seems to me
that there's many different definitions
and not all scientists seem to agree on
it so how do you think of phase
transitions why are they important okay
can I relate quickly before that is that
uh it's related it's your show yeah
you've reminded me that um so when you
uh as when you apply to be an
undergraduate in Oxford you have to go
to these interviews right and they last
for several days my mom was five days
actually of being sat in a room and be
called up to interview
yeah it's pretty I don't know if it's
yeah it's still about as thorough these
days it's still about three days
um I had a five day one but um one of
the interviews was uh with two tutors
and and they asked what is now a classic
interview question which is um uh you've
got some uh hot tea and you need to go
out soon so you're gonna add the add the
milk at some point to cool it down
should you add it sooner or later to to
get the tea to drinking temperature
faster
um and I didn't know the answer I was
trying to buy time so I answered that
etiquette dictates that you have to put
the milk in first regardless so I I
wasn't going to I I certainly wouldn't
uh put it in second because that
wouldn't be allowed
um
and and I tried I kept on that line for
about two attempts of them to to get me
to the answer while I was trying to
think and eventually one of one of the
tutors was American and he said okay
look I'm an American just imagine it's
American coffee and nobody cares about
etiquette
so that was his way around that
um sorry so yes phase transitions
um I mean they get to the heart of the
Magic in condensed matter physics I
think because I I think
um like so when you think about what it
is to do physics I the way I think of it
certainly theoretical physics is kind of
spotting hidden connections I'd say
um in the world take two phenomena the
same to normal people to be completely
unrelated and spot that they're actually
connected by kind of hidden secret
routes and isn't that ultimately what
what you do in Magic as well like I
think any way you try and think of magic
be it like
um in in fantasy fiction or you know if
you've got some magician trying to
present something I think they're always
trying to find these hidden connections
between things and and
um phase transitions are the the epitome
of this right because they they embody
this idea of um universality that
totally unrelated physical systems
behave identically at Phase transitions
so the the classic example and one I
mentioned in the book
um is it's it's water boiling to steam
uh but under pressure so it has to be
under a very high pressure at a specific
high pressure
um for it to to go through a phase
transition at what's called a critical
point
um now that same behavior you get at
that that critical point is then uh the
same as when a magnet stopped being
magnetic so you can take a
um a ferromagnet something that's
magnetic by itself
um and and if you heat it up Beyond a
specific temperature called its query
point then above that uh it stops being
a fairer magnet it starts being a
paramagnet which is not magnetic by
itself that can become magnetic when you
post it in a magnetic field and the way
in which it stops being magnetic uh is
the same as the way that uh water
stopped being a liquid and starts being
a gas at its critical point and that's
you know if someone told you that uh uh
water turning into steam and a magnet
stop being a magnet those were like
described by identical mathematics I
think you wouldn't naturally have
believed them we wouldn't have believed
them before before
they work in condensed metaphysics on
that subject and so you know when I say
that they're the same
um what you get is
um you get this kind of universal
Behavior like you can measure certain
properties of the system you look at how
they change as a function of some
parameter so with water turning into
steam you can look at the um the density
that that's uh something that you know
water is denser than steam you look at
other density changes as a function of
temperature and you'll find that
um it behaves as a power law the
identity goes as a as the temperature to
raise to some power and the power is
some totally random number is it was
something like 0.326 or something and we
can measure what this number is and you
might say okay maybe oh and then sorry
if you measure the magnetization of a
magnet as it stops being magnetic
um similarly it's it's governed by the
same
um Power and you say okay so there's
some magical like constant of reality
there it's like the speed of light or
something but it's not really that's the
thing it's just it's just some number
it's not some combination of pies or
ease or anything like that and and it's
it's really just uh the fact that it's
this kind of random number is the in
really interesting thing because there's
nothing that said all right it's not
some combination of known fundamental
constants that gives you that thing
they're just coming out exactly the same
and that's that's the really mysterious
thing when you measure these two
unrelated things carefully you find that
that they're really uh ultimately like
we think of them in the same way now and
that's that's uh the magic of phase
transitions I say
so
um the other thing I often kind of get
into arguments about with my condensed
matter friends or
um or others is the degree to which you
know Theory experiment and Technology
become sort of conflated with one
another I mean we often hear things like
well if you know if it wasn't for
quantum mechanics we wouldn't be able to
talk on an iPhone because you know an
iPhone has 14 you know trillion
transistors in it and uh because of that
that's the transistors quantum
mechanical but hey if you look at the
very first transistor you know and you
talk about it in the book uh but you
look at it it looks like it doesn't look
like something a wizard would make it
looks like something you know my uh
four-year-old would make you know after
I've deprived her of sleep for a couple
you know it's got coat hanger and
chicken you know chicken wire it's got
some chewing gum and it's got this you
know ginormous Crystal you know which
you're you know Philosopher's Stone
maybe you might think of it as doesn't
look anything like an iPhone uh moreover
I I claim and and you have by the way
you have one of the best descriptions of
how a transistor works I think it should
be you know included for for all uh
beginning uh undergraduates that you
should you should be very much
congratulated Felix it's it's one of the
best descriptions I've ever heard and
it's poetic as the book is and it's it's
accurate scientifically and it's just
it's just dead on and it I give it the
highest Commendation Felix I wish I
could have done it yeah so that's the
highest encomium you'll ever you'll ever
receive my friend thank you uh but the
uh transistor they didn't look at oh
here's the Schrodinger equation and uh
let's apply it and boom here's a now we
can use uh you know we can take
Instagram selfies
um what do you make of this like in
other words how does the basic physics
the path from basic physics to you know
or fundamental physics condensed matter
quantum mechanics to technology is is
completely it's almost incapable how how
it comes about but a lot but people
simplify it and they say well if you
don't believe you know uh in uh in
general relativity if you think the
Earth is flat you know don't use your
GPS uh you know so anyway to what extent
do we really ever look at the
fundamental laws to make technology I
claim it's almost never but I I might be
wrong
um I wouldn't say never
um
no I I think we do I I think we do it
quite a lot in condense matter if I'm
honest so maybe that's well that's a
controversial it's funny when I had
Duncan on Friday
when I had Duncan holiday on he was like
you know you should do things that are
useless he said like my in my Discovery
you know of topological matter uh with
castrolets and Dallas it'll never it'll
never result in a better iPhone but
that's not why we did it so anyway go on
so so give me some examples of where we
look into a fundamental law like here's
qcd or here is a Feynman diagram and out
pops technology as I said I'm taking the
counter example of I don't think it ever
happens but tell me what what are your
thoughts okay well I wouldn't say it
works like that that you you look at the
theory and the result pops out but
um you know the first I think one of the
examples I give in the in the book of an
early uh electronic device was uh this
point contact rectifier I mean it's
maybe the kind of thing you're referring
to a second ago where um
uh I think like American GIS in uh in
the second world war managed to
improvise an electronic device without
realizing it by kind of creating a
semiconductor again without knowing it
by um
uh which created a sort of what's called
a foxhole radio I think
um and the thing is you know they did
this with uh remarkably little stuff
they basically just had some headphones
um a safety pin
uh and and
um they they could make or what turned
out to be an electronic device now the
problem is okay you you have got the
basis of a working uh
um electronic device there but they
didn't know that at the time and I think
before it started being kind of
commercially useful that the this became
the transistor later on you had to
understand what was going on and why
that thing worked because only worked a
tiny percentage of the time uh and part
of that was we had no idea why it was
working so you to get you from the stage
where you've got just you're pushing two
things together and sometimes you're
getting a radio signal in your
headphones to having a functioning radio
that works very well we really did have
to understand many body physics to
understand that you know the quantum
mechanics of many
um
uh particles at once and I don't think
that's an overstatement you know it's
not a coincidence that uh we started
developing that many body theory in the
1950s and then the transistor comes
about also in the 1950s it's it's not
like
um random I I if I take an example
that's maybe a bit more um timely now
if you look at the development of um or
attempts to develop quantum computers I
think that's a really good place to look
um I mean looking at all this in a bit
of a more meta way I think the connects
matter physics more than other subjects
has this um like because it's practical
on a sort of shorter time scale it tends
to get a lot of like industry funding
again something that makes it look very
unmagical I think but if you look at a
lot of the brilliant discoveries in the
20th century that's matter physics lots
of them came out of places like um
uh why is my mind gone blank all of a
sudden the um
yeah so you know and again the important
thing with bell Labs is first it's got
loads of money uh but second they
allowed Blue Sky research much like how
they must say you know they they just
let people spend they got clever people
gave them the money to
um uh to be able to to do work they
wanted to and let them work on stuff
that seemingly had no point whatsoever
and then it led to many Nobel prizes
lots of these cheering Awards and so on
um all sorts of stuff now somewhere
where that's happening today you know
Bell Labs was was ultimately funded out
of money from uh
um the the Telecommunications industry
you know it came from about Alexander
Graham Bell ultimately I mean I think
the it was more Belle's emphasis on the
fact that he did kind of stuff that he
said he felt was pointless and it led to
one of the most important inventions uh
uh in the modern world
but
um so to take a a kind of current
example there's loads of money now going
into Quantum Computing uh that you know
huge investment it and it's this really
nice marriage of uh Theory and
experiment you know there's they're
taking on theorists there's uh but
there's also like a um uh a kind of
engineering side to it so we don't have
a kind of scalable quantum computer that
can okay we're doing some practical
stuff but you know it's not certainly
not something people are using
day-to-day for any useful purpose
um
but the approach is to try and make it
practical technology there's there's the
engineering side where you just
um you you just try and do better and
better and then there's the theory side
which says okay maybe a totally
different approach could lead to you
know something which is much simpler to
to create through engineering and the
way I've interacted with this subject is
through attempts to make a topological
quantum computer which is an arguably a
very theoretical approach maybe it's not
even the most practical one anymore it's
a very fast developing field but it's
it's not implausible that that could be
a good approach to it and so my former
colleague Steve Simon is you know a
well-known expert on on things related
to this and and the way he phrased it is
that um
if you want to harness quantum mechanics
you know at a
um to build something practical like a
quantum computer well quantum mechanics
only really works in you know you can
only maintain Quantum coherence in in
like very cold very clean systems it
it's it's
um it's very easy to lose this uh this
magical property of quantum mechanics
that makes it useful and so he said
there's two approaches to this one is
the engineering approach where you try
to minimize the noise the noise being
you know the messiness the the
temperature the uh so you try to make
things very cold you make them very
clean as the engineering approach the
other approach is to make the system
somehow deaf to the noise so rather than
just like minimize the noise you just
make it so that the noise is there you
don't care about it at all because
you've made something that doesn't care
about the noise and and that one of the
approaches to that then is is
topological quantum computers and I
think maybe Helen was underselling
himself if he said that his stuff is
never going to be useful
um I think there's always an eye with
the Nobel Prize being awarded to it
actually having some practical uses it
tends not to go to something that's
that's totally
um you know totally theoretical uh and
and I think like the the 2016 sorry 2016
um
Nobel Prize that you've mentioned a
couple of times now that that was for
topological matter and I think it is
going to have practical effects you know
I might be dreaming there but um I I
think things the the fact that it's been
taken seriously by people putting money
into Quantum Computing whether or not it
ends up being the Practical technology
that leads to it uh I think it shows
that there is this this connection and
that's really fundamental Theory playing
into practical technology I would say so
I think there's they're not totally
disconnected but I agree it probably is
oversold in a lot of places as well
and I want to ask you we're going to get
to you know questions uh because it's
getting late that uh over there in
Europe where you are and you're so
gracious to stay up late uh on a on a
Thursday uh but I do want to ask you you
know my existential questions which will
have some tie into your work and
especially the application of Arthur C
Clarke's quote on technology and Magic
but before we do that uh I guess the the
last thing that kind of resonates
throughout the book are sort of this
discussion of knots and and Knots as
this device so what is it about knots
that is uh so perhaps applicable in
terms of things like quasi-particles is
it merely a device is it merely a
mathematical analog you know is Hilbert
wonder you know uh you know and uh and
others about uh the fundamental laws
vigner's famous statement that you know
mathematics is unreasonably a effective
in physics so what what is this device
of knots why are they so important to
you and do they play a role in your
research as a theoretical condensed
matter physicist well they're certainly
very inspirational things I think they
were quite a an easy way to explain the
idea of topology you know when that
Nobel Prize was awarded uh you saw all
these journalists attempting to explain
what topological matter is and it was a
very hard task some achieved it you know
some maybe less so
um California Bagel or something yeah
yeah a lot of discussion of uh of bagels
and oranges and so on
um not I think make it make the make it
quite intuitive what's meant by topology
right because sort of a mathematical
knot is just like one you tie in your
shoelaces but you take the two friends
and you stick them together and so if
you imagine like a little string like a
shoelace and you can take it you can
just stick the two ends together like
that that's what gets called an unknot
because it's the simplest not it's like
unknotted you can think of it like sort
of like zero of knots if you imagine and
it actually looks like a zero as well
which is helpful then you can take it
and you conduct kind of try the simplest
knot you can imagine and put the two
ends together
um and the same so the next simplest one
after that is the uh the trefoil knot
um and you can just see that like
there's without cutting the string
um you can you can move it around as you
like but as long as you don't cut it and
rejoin it that thing is going to be
fundamentally different to the case of
the the unknots one one looking like
this the other one weaving around and
then rejoining and there are many
different ways you can do this so
I think the one of the main reasons I I
emphasize them heavily in the book is
there's a very natural connection to
this idea of magic I think I find them
quite inspirational
um these knots uh they're they're
present throughout uh various cultures
you know we all we all use them um I'm
getting married next week in the uh the
wedding ring is like an example of a
closed loop trying to symbolize infinity
and and connection between two people
and so on you know people um take
padlocks yeah there you go perfect and a
knot on your hand although you know what
I call you know what I call the wedding
ring Felix it might be too late but it's
also known as the world's smallest
handcuff I see yeah
my wife won't like that my wife does not
like that but luckily she doesn't listen
very often just kidding honey uh go on
Felix so congratulations before I forget
that's an amazing that's an amazing and
that'll truly be a transformative moment
for your life at a phase transition for
you and your and your bride to be uh but
but none as radical as when you guys
hopefully have kids but anyway please
continue well yeah so there are um some
hand binding ceremonies and stuff for
weddings so it's not uh it's not
unrelated this idea of um of melting so
it's something that I think people can
appreciate uh more generally and yeah
they do play an important role in Cadets
matter physics
um uh classifying the different types of
knots if you just imagine okay I can
take the thing and stick it together or
I can take it and I can do this thing
and stick it together or I can do
something more complicated which of
those ones can I transform into each
other ones that's a fun mathematical
problem
um and quite a deep one yes
um they do play a role in condensed
matter physics I mean essentially uh the
topological Quantum computation I
mentioned
um is entirely we think of it in terms
of not now that the way to make these
knots is
um I guess your readers are familiar
with uh things like creating particle
anti-particle pairs out of the vacuum
right is that is that a totally crazy my
audience is the most brilliant and the
known Multiverse yes that's right okay
so we can create so if you have time
going up this way you know there's a
space down here on a plane then we can
create a particle antiparticle pair pull
it apart and re-annilate it right and
you can think of that as the unknot then
in in a
um in in space-time you know uh okay and
there's famous well I'm not going to say
that I won't start talking about things
going back in time you create the pair
you pull it apart you stick it together
again and not now the the the things we
would try and make a topological quantum
computer out of are bizarre particles
that can only exist in matter as far as
we know where you can create them and
you can create another pair and you can
take these two and you can switch them
around switch their places I think in
some cases you can even switch them back
again now you try and take these two it
was originally it was created as a party
particle anti-particle pair you take
this one you pass around something else
over here and now you try and push them
back together again and they won't go
together and the reason they won't go
together is because they're no longer
particle anti-particle pair so this one
by virtue of having gone around
something else over here has ceased to
be the anti-particle of the thing that
it used to be and so in a very simple
way then you can see that okay if I'm
looking following the braids that I'm
making in this time Direction
um I've made something more complicated
actually tends to be called like a link
is when you have two different knots
linked together or something like this
and by doing that you can make it so
that things can't annihilate and so you
can at one way to look at it is you've
kind of encoded a history in in the
movement of these particles and the nice
thing is that these particles can now
you there's noise in the system there's
finite temperature making them Shake
around or there's disorder in the the
medium that they're being created in
but it doesn't care as long as the the
topology of the knot stays the same then
the quantum information can be encoded
in the same way in this way that is
robust to that noise and you see it's
the same as taking a shoestring tying it
in some knot and sticking ends together
I can move around as much as I like as
long as I don't actually break it and
rejoin it and it's still the same knot
and so essentially that is the the key
and massively simplified but the basis
of of how to approach topological
Quantum computation which could be a
very practical technology
okay so we are back all right Felix
we've come to the denouement where the
Wizards have to make their Journey Back
to the coven I guess you you taught me
that uh uh a a collective noun for
wizards is uh an argument is that right
that's what Terry Pratchett said yes it
sounds about right for academics doesn't
it okay
yeah and it sounds it sounds better than
uh the plural of turkeys which is the
rafter I don't know how that came to be
right um or and lawyers I I I've heard
maybe incorrectly lawyers are a coven a
coven of lawyers anyway uh at the end of
each uh interview I love to ask my guest
uh some questions and these are
existential questions these are meant to
evoke in The Listener uh something
something provocative perhaps and I want
to ask you this question that I really
started off the interview with which is
Sir Arthur C Clarke's famous statement
that any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic
um sometimes it can be inverted that any
sufficiently advanced magic is
indistinguishable from technology uh but
uh but in any case I want to ask you and
and this is kind of in the lines of
Richard feynman's famous cataclysm
question which was uh he was asked well
why what what statement contains the
most information in the fewest words
about the physical world and he said
that everything's made of tiny whirling
atoms that are a little miniature
systems of of subatomic particles were
acting in concert I want to ask you kind
of a similar type of question
um if all in all the exploration in your
field
uh what have you come upon that's sort
of the most magical if there is a you
know sui generis there is a particular
fact that you think is deserved of a
Feynman type cataclysm question you know
in other words something that would
endure and maybe have give reason for
humans to have Swagger so the Mandarin
question is what is the most impressive
form of magic that Wizards like yourself
have come up with in your estimation
okay there's a few I'd like to say uh
okay so if I boiled to the subject down
to its Essence I would say that the the
tagline for selling condensed matter
physics is that it's uh it's cases where
um
uh the hole is more than the sum of the
parts I think that would be my my
tagline for the subject and all the uh
fundamentally exciting phenomena you're
asking me about I think they all
embodied that very clearly
um
let's see I I think personally probably
the thing I'm really excited about is um
when we think about what is condensed
matter physics
again it's not really it's not really
Material Science right it's
fundamentally different to that it's not
chemistry although it has some overlap
it's not engineering but there's overlap
with that the theoretical end there's
philosophy it's not that but it has all
bits of all these things I had to think
about what's what's the thing that is
just pure condensed matter physics and
doesn't appear in any other branch of
physics and I think that's um the clear
example of that is is a quasi-particle
and I will be more specific I'll say the
uh the phone on is probably an example
of what you've asked for so uh the way I
try to explain these in in simple terms
a phone you know a photon is a particle
of light when we just give light it's
Quantum description we can say a beam of
light is made up of individual particles
uh called photons now uh sound doesn't
have that property you can have you know
sound waves but sound is not described
uh typically by Elementary where it's
not described by Elementary particles
right uh one way to say this is what we
mean by an elementary particle where you
could say it's something that can exist
by itself in the vacuum of space and
can't be reduced to other things with
that property so light is an example of
that a photon an atom can exist in space
but it can be reduced to electrons
protons and neutrons so that wouldn't be
an elementary particle in that sense
now you can see that rules out sound
because sound can't travel through space
so you're done
um so the Camino Elementary sound
particle but actually sound can travel
through any matter right
and when it travels through
um a crystal say uh we can describe it
in exactly the same way we describe
light as being carried by Elementary
particles we can describe sound as being
carried by particles but they're not
Elementary
and and this is what we call phonons
rather than photons so a phonon is like
a particle of sound and it can only
exist inside crystals uh or some other
states of condensed matter and you could
say well it's just the atoms vibrating
as the sound travels through the thing
you learn at school right
but the thing the reason I think the
subject is really so magical is that
actually if you look at the the
description of these things using
Quantum field Theory it's exactly the
same emergent description that you use
for
um describing particles like lights you
know the standard model of particle
physics it's still effective field
Theory right you know you'll know a lot
more about this than I will from there
the the cosmology side Astro particle
physics it's the standard models an
effective field Theory it's a
description of these particles
um sorry I lost you for a second
um yeah and and so in exactly the same
way phonons sure they're an effective
description but mathematically it's
exactly the same thing you do and I
think if you want to believe that
photons are real elements of reality I
think you should admit in the same way
the phonons are fundamental real things
in reality and so I suppose the the
philosophical point I'd want people to
to have as a take-home one for this
segment is that
um emergent stuff things where the whole
is more than the sum of the parts uh
things like phonons that's purely
emergent phenomenon right it's not
present in any one of the atoms there
that's vibrating it's some collective
behavior of lots of them uh but it's no
less real because all of your everything
you've ever experienced that is emergent
and so I think it's sort of backwards to
say oh the real things are like the
elementary particles the emergent stuff
is just something that comes out of that
I I'd say it's the other way around I'd
say your reality you experience all the
time is is real it's certainly real to
you
um and I think that should be taken more
seriously does that sound like a good uh
good answer for this section
yeah that's very good and I like that
you brought in uh the concept of
diversity which you know is overused in
my opinion we hear so much about it in
the states I'm sure it's the same in
Europe but it's obviously important but
you know diversity for its own sake is
is not necessarily you know a pure un un
alloyed you know benefit I mean you know
one of my friends likes to say you know
if you have diversity in the UK uh uh
you know you think driving on the left
is is really great but you think it
should be diverse we have people driving
on the right at the same time you know
that's not going to be so great uh but
when it's done in service of something
greater such as you know elevation of a
community
um by having multiple viewpoints from
practitioners with different backgrounds
and I I really appreciate that you
brought that in and it really did make
me think about how in the mission of
this book is in concert with Philip
Anderson's kind of observation that more
is different it's not better it's not
necessarily where first it might not be
fundamental but it's composite and to me
it seems like you could apply that as
sort of a theme of the book that more
people from diverse backgrounds is going
to be different and and hopefully
that'll add to the collective Endeavor
of the magic that we call physics and
this is such a delightful book I cannot
recommend it highly enough as I said I
give it the highest encomium possible
which is I wish I wrote several of it's
a segment so Felix Flickr will have
links here wonderful Royal Institution
talks I'm going to be there in June
to give a talk there of my own I'm gonna
have to hit you up for some uh for some
tips on how to give a conversation like
that at the site of my hero Michael
Faraday and the experiments and
magnetism and Fields that you describe
in this wonderful book I'll need your
help because I'm talking about Cosmic
polarization and its rotation uh through
things like magnetic fields in the
primordial universe so look forward to
that I look forward to meeting you in
person someday and I wish you most of
all uh great luck and success in your
upcoming nuptials that kind of bonding
of two quasi-particles uh is the most
Elemental and it is the most beneficial
to the furthering of of humanity so I
can't congratulate you highly enough
it's great you came out with this
wonderful book before the wedding
otherwise you'd be working on it on your
honeymoon so my friend Felix flicker I
like to know you and I hope we get to
meet in person someday thank you thanks
for having me
thank you